hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the melt weather champions chester
finals it's uh the clash that almost
never disappoints magnus carlsen vs
hikaru nakamura and this is the first
game of the match uh let's check it out
and see why it's uh why it's such an
outstanding game uh so magnus with the
white pieces opens with e4 we have e5 by
hikaru knight to f3 knights to c6 and
bishop to b5 magnus goes for the real
lopez knight to f6 hikaru goes for the
berlin defense and magnus plays d3
saying this will not be
a quick draw uh bishop to c5 and now
magnus captures in c6 bishop captures d
captures and now magnus castles and now
it's always a question in the berlin
defense how do you defend this e5 pawn
do you defend it with the queen uh do
you pin white's knight so you don't have
to defend it do you play bishop back to
d6 do you play knight to d7 so these are
all very uh playable options but he car
plays bishop to d6 which is not
all that common but it allows you uh so
maybe instead of knight to d7 you will
be able to develop your bishop to e6 and
guard the c4 square
as you know white is always planning to
bring this knight to c4
against the berlin to put pressure on
the bishop here and on the pawn so
knight b to d2 as planned we have bishop
to e6 which is now possible and b3 uh
further securing that c4 square but also
preparing to fianchetto the dark square
bishop so castles by hikaru bishop to b2
and now knight to d7 making uh
room for f5 to be played hikaru wants to
now uh start attacking on the king side
and well you could go for something like
knight to c4 and it's a move that has
been played here also queen to e2 is a
known move uh here magnus plays d4 and
it is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game
also a principal decision as if black
wants to attack on the king side you
always counter attack in the center of
the board also goes for the queen side
as well uh so what can hikar do here uh
well now going f5 would be uh too
adventurous because it's just an easy
win for white we're just gonna capture
on f5 and after let's say rook captures
we're going to capture on e5 as well and
after bishop captures now we capture on
e5 after knight captures we simply play
queen to e2 and we win there's a double
attack on the knight here if the knight
moves you're going to lose the bishop
and it doesn't matter if you add another
defender we simply add another attacker
and there's no way for black to add
another defender so here you're just
losing that uh either knight or bishop
so of course uh hikaru did not play a f5
he car solidified with f6
now magnus trades in the center d
captures f captures and queen to e2 now
preparing to bring the rooks into the
game queen to e7 hikaru also connects
rooks and now a4 magnus always enjoys
these a4a5 h4 h5 moves because they
constrict
black uh in well doing whatever black
wants to do
and it's uh well it's just what we've
learned from our good friends uh the the
engines these days so rook to f7 he car
now ready to double up on the f file and
h3 by magnus we have rook 8 to f8 and
now rook 8 to d1
uh we have h6 and now knights to h2 now
the knight um uh well this night it's
still a question of where this knight is
going but probably the c4 and then to e3
and then maybe to f5 this knight also
has some ideas of that maybe in the
future you can move the rook maybe
knight f1 knight to g39 to e3 knight to
f5 knight to d5 so these are the usual
squares for tonight but uh all depends
on what black plays so here here carl
plays c5 uh grabs more control of over
the d4 square but it kind of releases
the control over the d5 square so now
this is also an available square for uh
magnus's knight he plays knight the c4
and now he puts pressure on the bishop
here but also just knight the e3 to d5
or f5 is a perfectly fine idea we have
rook to f6 by hikaru uh now preparing to
bring bring the rook over to g6 maybe
and now comes a queen to d3 by magnus
you could also play a knight to g for to
kind of put pressure on that rook and
get black to trade off this um a light
square bishop but it's it's nothing for
c car could just move the rook back so
instead we have queen to d3 by magnus
and now queen to f7
uh so what do you play here well here
magnus played f3 if you go for this
knight capture some d6c captures and
queen captures on d6 yes you win a pawn
but only uh for this one movie because
after bishop captures an h3 hikaru
already wins the pawn back and now your
queen's attacked you can't grab the
knight the bishop also defends the
knight so nothing nothing really is
happening here so f3 magnus just
solidifies here and now h5 by hikar
preventing knights to g4 uh we have
knight captures and e6c captures and now
queen to e3 magnus wants to bring the
queen to g5 even though now queen
captures on d6 is a very tricky idea
because now if bishop captures an h3
queen to c7 and it's a it's a really
crazy position where uh
uh
a lot of things are hanging bishop is
saying there's a lot of pressure on the
knight here the there's a lot of
pressure on this pawn here uh but after
queen to g6 threatening checkmate it's a
completely wild position where white is
better but
you do not want to play this so magnus
goes for the uh for the mo you know
more sane approach queen to e3 going for
g5 queen to e7 by hikaru and now queen
to g5 great getting ready to pick up
this pawn and now comes the reason
behind hikaru's queen to e7 he plays
rook to e8 so what's what's the idea
here uh well if magnus grabs the pawn
then hikaru's plan is uh just a rook to
h6 so if the queen was here then white
would just be able to trade queens but
now you don't have a square for your
queen your queen is trapped and hikaru
just wins so magnus just plays rook to
f2
now with ideas of maybe doubling up on
the d file and bishop to f7 now the pawn
is nicely defended and now uh this
knight that's been doing not all that
much here goes to f1 and now knight to
e3 to f5 or d5 uh that's
what we usually go for hikaru also
starts horsing around knight to f8 the
knight is now coming to d6 will attack
the queen so the queen will have to
retreat somewhere queen back to d2 right
away putting pressure on this pawn so if
you go knight to e6 now then we can grab
the spawn so knight the g6 by hikaru and
knight to e3 now we're kind of
threatening knight to d5 attacking the
queen and the rook and hikaru will have
to part with his light square bishop
but
he doesn't go for that a very
interesting idea is knight to f4
because it's so it's such a great square
for the knight but after knight to f5 uh
hikaru would have this option of maybe
sacrificing the exchange and after pawn
captures just d5 and these pawns are
very very impressive here so it's uh
something that you could play but uh
if uh if you if you feel up to it hikaru
played knight the h for instead now puts
a lot of pressure on
uh the position here uh if if the queen
somehow got around over for example to
g6 then you would have insane pressure
here uh so uh king to h2 just getting
the king away from that g file and now
king to h7 by hikar we have rook d to f1
and now magnus wants to uh somehow get
this bishop into the game and to do that
he has to play f4 so how do you do this
well hikaru first blocks it we have
knight to g6 and now knight to f5
attacking the queen queen to f8 and now
only now f4 that's how we make progress
in this game knight captures on f4 and
now of course we temporarily give up the
exchange rook captures on f4 e captures
on f4 and finally bishop captures on f4
we have g captures on f4 now hikaru's
defenses have been completely shattered
and this is a fine moment in the game
where
uh magnus has the opportunity to to you
know pick up some pawns and he can
capture the pawn with the queen he can
capture the pawn with the knight he can
capture this uh pawn with the rook he
can capture this pawn with the queen and
uh you know if you had this position or
me or anyone else we would probably go
for queen captures on f4 it's just
closer to the black king or maybe even
rook captures then try and shift our
rook over into the attack or even knight
captures with a double attack here the
bishop and rook would be attacked and
the queen would still be able to capture
on f4 but not magnus magnus just plays
queen captures on f4 he says uh i can
win a pawn i'm ready to go straight into
the end game
and this is basically where our end game
starts uh hikaru has to trade we have
queen captures on these six knight
captures now
attacking the rook and the bishop so the
rook has to defend and now rook captures
an f4 and magnus is up upon how will he
continue this with king the g6 by hikaru
king g3 we have bishop to e6 now trying
to constrict the the white king from
going any further but now rook to f3 and
this is a fine maneuver rook to f3 king
to f4 and then rook to g3 to force the
black king away from uh such an active
square b6 hikaru improving his pawn
chain and now king to f4
we have h4 not allowing rook to g3 check
and now pawn to g4 and it's a really
really uh tricky position for example
it's a question whether or not to do
capture h captures on g3 alpha song
or do you play something else but what
else is there if you play something like
rook to d7 go after the knight knight to
f5 is perfectly fine just goes after
this pawn here and if you trade for
example e captures uh with check king to
f7 now rook to d3 of course you can't go
into a king and pawn end game because
you're down a pawn so black would have
to avoid the trade and now g5 is enough
for white to win for example captures
capture so you're going to win this pawn
as well and the two pawns here will be
enough for you to win so after g4 hikaru
has the capture on g3 alpha
rook captures with check king the h7 now
the king will be trapped here for a very
long time you don't really have access
to any of the other squares and you kind
of don't want to go all the way into
white's position so came to h7 and now
h4 uh so now hikaru's king isn't all
that active but he still has uh the rook
and the bishop so rook the d7 attacks
the knight now e5 just uh the the knight
will either remain there or you will get
a very active position for your king so
hikaru trades uh this comes with czech
king captures and now bishop backed the
g8 defending uh and now knight to f5 so
this is a very unpleasant position for
black
the rook can't really go anywhere you
can't check the white king if you uh
leave the seventh rank just rook g7
check is enough to win the game we're
gonna start picking off those spawns uh
and uh you okay rook the d5 check is
possible uh but then king f6 and it's
really really ugly if king to h8 we just
play rook captures and g8 king captures
and now this fork wins us the game so
after knight to f5 we have king the h8
by hikaru now comes c4 improving the
position before doing anything uh
uh that uh might you know change the
character of the game uh we've rooked to
d1 and now knight to e7 putting pressure
on this bishop here so bishop to h7 and
now knight to d5 uh what you play here
now the king can easily approach that
queen side and start picking off those
pawns
but hikaru says all right but what about
your h pawn i can just play rook to h1
so this is what hikaru does but magnus
says i don't need the extra pawn because
my king is much more active and he just
plays knight to f6
so what can hikaru do well there's
really nothing better other than
capturing the pawn so rook captures on
h4 is played
in the what now now knight captures on
h7 magnus even trades down into a rook
and pawn end game with equal material
because it's just enough uh so king
captures an h7 now comes king to d6 and
is this enough or did magnus maybe
uh put too much optimism into into uh
well not just the the position but also
his endgame skill uh well rook the h6
check king to c7 and now rook to f6 of
course white's plan is just to go king
b7 and start picking off those pawns so
hikaru has to get ready to prevent this
so here king to b7 rook the f7 with
check we have king a6 by magnus and now
rook the c7 by hikaru and this is a very
interesting move because uh
you know what carlson's play plan is
carlson's plan is to just bring the rook
over to a8 and win the spawn and then
win the game and the blacks only counter
play will be to go after the queen side
pawn so it
it looks kind of redundant maybe to
give you an extra move uh so to say
maybe rook to d7 makes more sense
because then you just have two moves to
go after white's b3 pawn this way you'll
have three moves but okay i'm sure
hikaru had a very good reason for
placing the rook on c7 uh rook to d3 now
you have to you can't go of course here
because the king covers that so you have
to play this to go after the the a7 pawn
and now hikaru can finally start
activating his king king to g6
rook to d8 by magnus and now rook to e7
getting ready to go after that b3 pawn
and now how do you how do you continue
this game it's a it's a really really
tricky position uh so feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out how to
win this game uh for white well i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh on choosing either
of the two moves because they're the
only moves that basically we can play
here uh and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is rook to b8
or rook to a8 and the reason why it's
both is that rook to b8 is just uh more
natural and rook to a8 is super
complicated but i'm first going to show
the super complicated one just because i
know how much you guys enjoy this
because it seems like uh
a bit more reasonable to go after the
pawn right away we're going to capture
it and move faster the problem is things
could get very complicated if you go
rook to a8 and magnus spent uh a decent
amount of time when deciding between
rook to a8 so
and rook to b8 the the the point is
after rook to a3 now we have to capture
with the king the if we capture with the
rook then after rook captures on b3 for
example rook to b7 we go after the pawn
rook to b4 and now after rook captures
on b6 we're just going to play king to
f5 of course we're not interested in
grabbing the rook and of course if white
captures he puts our pawn on b4 and we
are very very close to promotion so here
let's say a5 we would play king the e4
rook the d6 now cutting off the king now
king to e5 and after rook to d5 check
let's say rook captures um uh so king to
e6 rook captures on c5 and now king to
d7 and even though white is up two pawns
you cannot win this end game uh because
uh
uh the rook has no squares you can't
move the rook anywhere along the c file
then we're just going to pick up this
spawn and the white king is in the
corner can't really do anything
there's no way to advance here for white
so this would be very very
tricky so
rook day 8 is possible but like i said
after rook to a3 you have to capture
with the king and then after rook
captures on b3 play rook to b8 and now
after king f5 now we play rook captures
on b6 and after let's say rook to a3
going after this pawn we play king to a6
so it's a bit of a different idea but
king captures with check rook captures
with checking the b5 now rook to a1
getting out and now king captures on c5
now this position would be winning but
as you can see there's quite a lot to
consider magnus played rook to b8
instead and now he just wants to play
rook to b7 and then pick up the the a7
pawn so king f5 this allows hikaru to
throw in an extra move with the king now
rook b7 and rook to e3 of course we're
going after these pawns king captures on
a7 rook captures on b3 and now magnus
doesn't grab the b6 pawn but
instead he plays a5 of course black
cannot capture uh we're gonna pick up
the rook here so rook the b4 he goes
after carlson c4 pawn and now magnus
advances the pawn all the way to a6 uh
so what can hikaru do king the e5
there's nothing really if you don't have
the king into the game rook captures on
b6 we have rook captures on c4 now the
material is equal
but king to b7 crossings king is now
pawn is now becoming a queen rook to a
for hikaru's last hope is to sacrifice
the rook for the pawn and then try and
promote his own pawn a7 and now hikaru
just captures that pawn rook captures on
a7 with check king captures and now c4
so what can magnus do magnus just played
rook to c6 and he was in this position
on move 65
that hikaru nakamura resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here the problem is white king will be
just in time to grab this pawn for
example king to d4 we're ready to escort
our pawn down the board king to b6 now
after pawn to c3 we play king to b5 and
now you can't advance the pawn further
because the rook will capture it so
black has to waste the move with king to
d3 now king b4 and now after c2 we play
king b3 and black is uh one move short
of promoting this pawn to a queen uh if
you move it the rook will just capture
so you have you're gonna have to waste
the move with the king and then we'll
capture he do with check and then we
easily checkmate the black king
uh so really really an impressive game
but the part that i really enjoyed the
most was uh
uh
here let me just quickly rewind this
this moment here where you really could
just capture anything and white is still
better but magnus just goes for uh
straight for the end game uh he trades
queens and goes into the end game being
up upon not something a lot of people
would choose a lot of people would
prefer more pieces on the board
but it seems that magnus is extremely
confident in his end game technique and
also he's playing against hikaru who who
well enjoys
complications in
in time trouble so
trading the queens here is definitely
the the sounder choice for him
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it and that you've improved
your end game at least a little bit with
this video
i would like to thank david kimura
myself for making great videos vladolaro
king and bulmark uprealty and cumitu for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day